visit minnesota for freezing for many
years and now he's uh
at usc in electrical and computer
engineering
works in all sorts of areas in network
systems
and distributed control and
look forward to hearing your work
thank you sean uh thanks for this kind
of introduction and for your invitation
to participate in this
exciting workshop so i'll be talking
about convergence and sample complexity
of gradient methods for the model 3
linear quadratic regulator problem
and this work done by my phd student has
some in collaboration with my former
student imposdo carmine and
my friend and colleague marty at usc
so as all of you know an important theme
in this workshop is whether we can learn
controllers
potentially for complex dynamical
systems that operate in certain
environments
in the absence of first principle models
perhaps by strategically using data that
we have at our disposal and obviously
this is a challenging question
and in order to make some progress and
to see how much mileage we can get
it is instructive actually to narrow
scope a little bit and to perhaps
examine standard problems that we know
how to handle
when we have models uh in the absence of
models so
in view of that i'm going to to consider
a classical problem in control theory
that
has 60 year old history namely the
linear quadratic regulator problem
and this problem involves minimization
of a quadratic cost for
linear linear dynamical systems and
there are many different variations so
the
theme and perhaps the simplices is
instance
arises for linear time invariant
dynamical systems that it
evolves quadratic causes that we want to
minimize over an infinite
infinite horizon just for the sake of
convenience and for personal taste i'm
going to
focus on continuous time dynamical
systems whatever i tell you today
holds in discrete time as well and the
model is given by
this first order vector-valued ordinary
differential equation that governs the
evolution of the
n-dimensional state vector x in the
presence of a control
input u and the random initial condition
x naught
whose distribution we assume to to to
know these matrices a and b
are constant matrices for linear time
invariant systems and they determine
model
parameters a is a dynamical generator
and matrix b
tells us how control input enters into
the state equation and matrices q and r
are positive definite matrices that
specify state and control weights what i
need to highlight is that minimization
is done over
all state and control trajectories and
the optimal solution
is given by a linear feedback policy
namely at any time instant at any t
you obtain you form optimal control
action by
acting on the vector of available state
measurements by this fixed matrix k
and this fixed matrix can be obtained
from a positive definite solution
of a celebrated algebraic riccati
equation
and under mild system theoretic
conditions namely well-known
controllability and
observability requirements there is a
unique positive definite solution to
this quadratic equation which provides
optimal stabilizing feedback gain
feedback gain that
not only minimizes the quadratic cost
for linear dynamical system but also
provides closed loop
stability and if you have a model there
are efficient
linear algebraic and iterative
techniques that you can utilize to
compute
solution to recap equation however the
challenge that arises is what to do in
situations where you don't have
model parameters namely these matrices a
and b
and perhaps one approach that you may
want to utilize
is to use strategic data to estimate
matrices a and b and then to to proceed
down the standard route so the approach
that we are going to take is slightly
different we are going to tap
into the area of model 3 reinforcement
learning and to attempt to learn
feedback policy by optimizing over
feedback gain case
and you can easily express uh lqr cost
in terms of the feedback gain matrix
matrix
and challenges that arise in this
context
is first of all to establish convergence
properties this is
a challenging question because it is a
standard fact that the lqr cost is a
non-convex function
of the feedback gain and in the absence
of models you have also a burden to
establish statistical properties namely
sample complexity of your gradient
gradient-based
algorithms and what i'm going to tell
you in the next couple of slides
is very briefly to list our
contributions
in in in this area and the rest of my
talk is going to be devoted
to explaining essentially what we what
we've done in comparing to the state of
the art so our first contribution
is to show exponential stability over
the set of stabilizing feedback gains
for gradient flow dynamics for the
linear quadratic regulator problem for
continuous time
systems it is a little bit more
convenient to work with differential
equations than with
uh recurrence relations but it turns out
that actually
even gradient is sent for continuous
time lqr
inherits property that we established
for
for this ordinary differential equation
namely we can show
linear convergence over the set of
stabilizing feedback gains with a fixed
step size
alpha so these results are relevant even
in the context when you have your model
namely even when you have
matrices and b at your disposal
and uh you know i'll tell you
essentially how
how how we establish give you at least a
flavor of how we establish these
these properties in the absence of
models
what we've done we improved linear
convergence
uh over the set of stabilizing feedback
gains and established logarithmic
complexity with respect to the
reciprocal of the desired accuracy of
the random search method for the
linear quadratic regulator problem
that'll be very specific what i mean by
random search
method what i would like to highlight is
that all of our results hold with high
uh probability and we do everything
offline
so if you expect regret type bounds and
results of that sort
none of that is going to be present in
my talk today and
i would like to draw your attention to
our archive posts
that that has been also conditionally
accepted for publication in italian
sections on automatic control so the way
i'm going to present my results i'm
going to start from the second result
because
that's a topic that is of interest to to
this
audience and then if time permits i'll
i'll go back to
to establishing uh properties of
gradient flow dynamics but before i do
that
i would like just briefly to highlight
uh key features that allow you to
establish linear convergence of gradient
descent
in the absence of convexity namely if
you manage to show that your lqr cost
possesses smoothness and gradient
dominance
properties over the sub-level its
sub-level sets then you can show
actually
linear convergence of gradient descent
and this is exactly what
university of washington group led by
mariam fazel
and kovacs has has done a couple of
years ago for the discrete-time linear
quadratic regulator
and we proved similar properties for the
continuous time problem using completely
different proof
proof techniques and that hopefully i'll
get a chance to highlight in the second
part
of my talk so so let me start with the
random search method for
lqr so and highlight our results
uh regarding convergence and sample
complexity the challenge that you are
facing in the model 3 setup
is that you don't have access to true
gradients you can namely you can only
access random function values perhaps by
running experiment
or by tapping into simulation engine
that domain experts
have developed and they're kind enough
to allow you to run simulation in the
presence of a certain feedback gain and
a certain initial condition and you can
obtain random function values and then
lqr objective is obtained by computing
expectation
over initial conditions that we assume
to be zero mean unit variance with
bounded sub
sub gaussian norm uh
so uh this slide summarizes what i mean
by random
search method for model 3 lqr it's
essentially
a technique that attempts to emulate
properties of gradient descent
by estimating gradient using random
function values
and we tap into the area of derivative
reoptimization
uh techniques that
you may want to utilize are listed here
uh they're respectively given by two and
one point
gradient estimates and if you take a
look at these expressions they may
remind you of a central different
standard central difference scheme
from from numerical analysis the
key difference between them is that in
two-point scheme you assume that you can
evaluate lqr cost at two different
values
of the feedback gain but for the same
initial condition
and this obviously can be clearly can be
a very restrictive uh assumption
especially in situations when you
don't have simulation engine at your
disposal and you need to run experiments
but
it is well known that two point schemes
have better variance
reducing properties relative to one
point schemes where you assume that you
can evaluate
lqr cost at one value of the feedback
gain for particular initial condition
so as you change with the gain you
you can only evaluate it for different
initial conditions so
so again two point schemes have clear
advantage and i'll i'll demonstrate this
uh in a couple of minutes so this
approach here
utilizes a single sample but obviously
nothing prevents you from running
multiple simulations and using mini
batch gradient estimate to form your
such such direction in the random search
method
and the relevant question that arises
here is how many samples you need
in order to emulate properties of
gradient descent how long simulation
time
you should utilize and what is the total
number of iterations so
these three parameters essentially
determine sample complexity
of your your model 3 algorithm
and this probably the most important
slide in my talk it summarizes our main
results
in which we establish that random search
lqr
that utilizes two points gradient
estimate achieves a desired accuracy
epsilon with high probability
if the number of iterations is of order
log of one over epsilon
namely if the number of iterations is of
order
that is logarithmic with respect to the
reciprocal
of the accuracy and if the number of
samples per iteration
is depends linearly on the state
dimension of the
number of components in the state vector
let's say if you have mechanical
standard mechanical system let's say
mass spring damper system
your state vector would be containing
two components position and velocity
perhaps so your mechanical system
if number of samples is linear in the
in the problem dimension then
we we uh have desired accuracy with
with high high probability and what i
would like to highlight is that
in contrast to uh other results in the
literature
uh number of samples does not depend on
the desired accuracy
c is a constant here that depends on
problem roman data model parameters but
it does not depend on the desired
accuracy and sample complexity is
obtained by multiplying these two
numbers so it's essentially linear in
the
problem dimension and logarithmic with
respect to the reciprocal
of the accuracy so let me very briefly
uh
compare and contrast our results to
state-of-the-art
in the literature and what i would like
to highlight is an impressive paper by
uc berkeley group where they established
sublinear convergence
with polynomial sample complexity and
decreasing step size
using a single sample and they
clearly demonstrated advantages of two
point schemes
over one point gradient estimation
uh schemes and in addition to that they
show that
if you if you have a luxury of using one
point mini batch
estimate with one point scheme they
confirmed essentially
earlier result of a university of
washington group where
you can actually establish linear
convergence rate with a fixed step
size but with polynomial complexity
universal uc berkeley group improved
actually complexity bounds significantly
related to uw
from one over epsilon to the fourth to
to one over epsilon to the square
but still complexity that they
established this polynomial
uh with respect to the reciprocal of the
desired accuracy
in our case we have logarithmic
complexity and the question is how do
you establish these results so what kind
of
approach do you need to use in your
proof to to
establish results one perhaps
natural uh avenue is to try to attempt
gradient estimation error and this is
essentially what
uh what a standard technique would be
what i would like to highlight is that
that we don't do that
what we do we explore the problem
structure and utilize
uh results from non-asymptotic uh
statistics to show that gradient
estimate concentrates with high
probability when projected to the
direction of the gradient
again we don't attempt to control
variance
of the gradient estimation error as we
approach
uh optimal solution but rather we just
show that gradient investment
concentrates with high probability and
this allows us actually to to
improve bounds that have been uh
established in in the literature so
in our proof we uh tap into standard
results in optimization we
utilize approximate gradient descent and
it is standard fact that
approximate gradient descent can
converge with a fixed step size
provided that your direction
has a projection that is uh
big enough and that its norm in
in the direction of the gradient and
that its norm does not become
too large as measured by the norm of the
gradient and these two conditions hold
in the deterministic
setup these two parameters data one and
theta two enter into a fixed step size
in addition to
smoothness parameter and pl type of a
parameter and both of them have
interesting geometric interpretation
that is
uh you know plotted here unfortunately
don't have time to to go into this
rather than going into details what i
would like to highlight is that in our
case
we need to establish actually that these
two results hold
with with high probability and this is
actually what hasa managed to
to to prove so rather than again
providing technical details what i would
like to do is
just to give you an example uh that
illustrates perhaps
flavor of our result this is just a
mechanical system that contains a number
of inverted pendulum cards that are
connected with
masses and and dampers and each
cart is controlled by a force control
and you would like to
design a model model-free lqr around
certain operating
points and what this slide shows
is essentially here we display
histograms
of uh these two expressions that i
listed at the
at a couple of slides ago being equal
to the to these values that that are
plotted
along the horizontal axis and if you
choose this parameters theta 1 and theta
2
carefully with overwhelming probability
uh
you know these two these two events are
going to be to be satisfied and
convergence curves
establish linear convergence without
typical uh
oscillations that you have in stochastic
type of algorithms so
so this was a very very brief overview
of what we've done in in the area of
model 3
linear quadratic regulator again for
details i would like to
uh to direct you to to
to our paper all of the details are
contained there but uh
at this point what i would like to do i
would like to switch gears
a little bit and to go back to the setup
when we have model and to
perhaps highlight what it takes to
establish
global exponential stability of the
gradient flow dynamics for the lqr
problem even in the absence of convexity
and i
i feel that this part is perhaps going
to be useful to outsiders who controls
community because it's going to
highlight
some of the standard techniques that uh
control theorists are familiar with but
that you know outside of
you know cbc and acc conferences that we
go to are not that well known and well
appreciated so
uh the first point that i would like to
highlight is that
as soon as you express lqr cost in terms
of the fitbit gain matrix you lose
convexity and you need to trust me that
you can write lqr cost
over the set of stabilizing feedback
gains
using this expression here where k is a
feedback gain that you would like to
design again q and r
state and control baits and
x is a closed-loop covariance matrix of
your state vector
so it turns out actually that you can
write this matrix x
in terms of the feedback gain k using
this integral
representation and one reason why you
don't have convexity
is because in general matrix exponential
is not a convex function
of its argument over feedback gain in
this case another reason
for uh loss of convexity is that
set of stabilizing feedback gains is not
a convex set
this is well-known fact in in uh
control theory so for at least two
reasons you don't have convexity
of the lqr cost when you express it in
terms of the fitbit gain matrix
so what we want to do we would like to
analyze gradient flow
and gradient descent dynamics and to
establish
its properties so the question that
arises is what is known about this
problem
even though it is non-convex what kind
of standard results can we tap into
in order to make some progress and uh
again i would like to highlight that
global convergence properties for
discrete time linear quadratic regulator
problems were established by university
of washington group and we've done
similar things
for for both continuous time and
discrete time
using different proof techniques that
i'm going to highlight right now
so what has been known for over 35 years
is that in spite of lack of convexity
lqr cost has a unique critical point and
this unique critical point is given by
the
optimal solution that you can when you
have models contain
obtained from cut equation another
interesting property is radial
unboundedness
of the lqr cost namely as you approach
the set of
boundary of the set of stabilizing
feedback gains or as your feedback gain
shoots to infinity
your lqr cost blows up and again this
has been known
for a while these two properties
allow you actually to use objective
error as a lapuna function for the
gradient flow dynamics
namely it's trivial to show that if you
utilize objective
error the difference between lqr cost
and its optimal value
you can show that its derivative dot
here
represents the derivative with respect
to time along the solutions of the
gradient flow
dynamics is negative definite along the
set of stabilizing feedback gains and
this is enough to establish asymptotic
stability
of the gradient flow dynamics over the
set of stabilizing feedback so
asymptotic stability global convergence
to a unique critical point comes for
free it's literally a two-liner
that taps into standard results that
were established 35
years ago all hard effort and heavy
lifting has to be done
to show rate of convergence to establish
exponential
rate of convergence and what i would
like to remind you
is that pl type of a condition uh
allows you actually to to relax
strong convexity requirement on the
objective function and to show linear
convergence so exponential convergence
in the context of
continuous time dynamical systems if pl
condition
holds on the top of the requirements
that are listed on the previous page
we cannot only establish negative
definiteness
of the derivative of of this yapuno
function candidate along the solution of
our system but we can
show that the bound
is proportional to to the to the lapuna
function the
row here is a pl parameter and this is
enough actually
to show that you have exponential
stability and again an example
of a function that satisfies pl
condition is given by a strongly convex
objective function unfortunately
we don't even have convexity let alone
strong complexity
right and the question is how can we how
can we go about establishing that pl
condition
holds for the for the lqr cost and the
way we do this
is very different from the approach that
university of washington group
used we actually utilize the standard
convex reparametrization
from from control c theory and then go
back to the original set of coordinates
and establish relation between
them so so let me let me just give you a
flavor of how this is done you need to
trust me
that you can write linear quadratic
regulator problem
uh as listed here namely lqr cost that i
listed couple of slides ago
we would like to minimize it with
respect to feedback gain matrix k
and this covariance matrix x under the
following two
um constraints positive definiteness of
the covariance matrix
is equivalent and guarantees closed loop
stability stability of your
control system and this equation here
is a lapuna equation standard equation
in
in control theory that tells you how
uh closed loop covariance matrix is
related to your
your feedback gain and to your model
parameters so any student of
optimization would immediately recognize
that this is
quadratic equation in your optimization
variables and
as you know quadratic convex
optimization does not tolerate
quadratic equality constraints we need
to have linear equality constraint in
order to have convex problems so
however optimization variables enter
into your
uh quadratic equality constraint in a
convenient way
and if you stare at this equation long
enough you may notice that if you
introduce
change of variables if you introduce new
variable y
which is given by a product of the
feedback gain k and covariance matrix
x this quadratic equality constraint is
going to become linear constrained
now in variables x and y and this
variable y
has the same number of rows and columns
as a feedback gain matrix and
under closed loop stability you can go
back and forth
between y and k without any any loss of
information
and it turns out actually that
you can rewrite now your problem in the
following form this problem turns out to
be
jointly convex in variables x and y your
quadratic equality constraint has become
linear
and what control theories would
typically do we would utilize sure
complement here to bring it into
semi-definite
programming characterization which is
dual essentially to the algebraic record
equation
this is not what we do here our approach
is to express covariance matrix
in terms of this new matrix y
and you can do that and the express
actually covariance matrix is an affine
function of this matrix y
there these calligraphic symbols
a and b are linear operators that are
listed
listed here and once you do that you can
write
f of k as a convex function
of this new variable y which again has
the same number of rows and columns
as as your fitbit gain matrix k
very good so you have convexity new
variables
right and now if you
if you're happy with working in y
coordinates
then you you need to study gradient flow
in y coordinates over the convex
landscape in addition to convexity
actually
it turns out that you have strong
convexity of the over the sub-level sets
of the lqr cost in this new set of
coordinates
right has some very skillfully managed
to show
that in addition to convexity we have
strong convexity where
this set here is nothing but a sub-level
set
over the set of stabilizing matrices by
if you want to in this new coordinates
once you have strong convexity
all results come come for free because
pl condition is immediately satisfied
and you
you you can essentially establish
exponential stability without any issues
and this is exactly what we've done
in in our paper we established ex
exponential stability over uh
the set of stabilizing if you want to
matrices
why not uh for for for the
of the corresponding gradient flow
dynamics this is very nice
very elegant however it doesn't tell us
anything about the property of the
gradient flow dynamics in the original
coordinates
right and since i was instructed to
speak for 25 minutes and i'm already at
26
i'm not going to to have a chance to go
into details but
what i want to advertise essentially is
that
if you take a look at our paper we
established very nice relation
between gradient flow dynamics uh
over this context landscape to the
gradient flow dynamics or non-non-convex
landscape using
geometric relation between these
matrices
y and k and you know some some
additional techniques that are pretty
standard in optimization
and you know that allows us to allow us
to establish these strong properties
again
i don't have time to go through these
details i felt that you know this is
way more closer to the background of the
audience but perhaps this change of
variables was
a new new aspect that uh outsiders
controls community haven't seen before
and again this is very different from
from a proof technique that university
of washington group use with this
i'd like to to wrap up my talk by
telling you that there are
lots of additional challenges in this
rapidly
evolving landscape and the problem that
is
of interest to me personally is a
structured feedback synthesis perhaps
for the purpose of designing
distributed controllers their control
action is formed by utilizing limited
information exchange between different
subsystems and this turns out to be
a very very interesting problem because
the standard change of variables that i
utilized
a few slides ago is no longer
enough to bring you into into convex
parameterization the reason being that
arbitrary sparsity pattern
on k does not easily translate into
sparsity patterns on x and y
and you know if you stare enough at
these
expressions here you'll you'll quickly
realize that this is this is the case so
standard change of variables does not
work so there are interesting questions
even when you have models and obviously
output feedback reinforcement learning
that you don't have a luxury
of having access to state measurements
but rather just to
to noisy output measurements is is a big
big challenge for for reinforcement
learning with this i'd like to
list references that uh
uh that have been useful to us and our
own
own papers in addition to the paper that
i mentioned archived posts we also
extended all of these results for
discrete time case and this was already
published in
uh control systems letters so
uh the most important slide i'd like to
thank hassam
for uh his hard and brilliant work
and uh armin and magdy for for being
outstanding collaborators and
of course sources of funding air force
office of scientific research and
national science foundation
thank you ah bravo
that's a wonderful work um so yes so
let's um
have a question or two and then go
straight to the panel right
um if i screwed up the schedule
um and we have a break i'm sorry um oh
that's right that's on the end
excuse me i got myself flustered um so
quick a quick question before the break
anybody
yeah i i wanted to ask you about uh the
discrete time
is there a nice and elegant way of
transporting the convenience time
results to discrete time
i wish there was so
unfortunately geometry in this great
time case is different
but uh all of these uh
if you if you take a look at this
formulation
here what would be different is that uh
le poon of equation has different
form but there is an equivalent convex
reparametrization even in discrete-time
case
and whatever we presented in continuous
time carries over actually to
to discrete time if you if your question
was if we start with discrete time
dynamics do these results extend
they do if your question was if instead
of gradient flow dynamics
uh i utilize gradient descent the answer
is again
affirmative right we showed actually
that with the fixed step
size forward euler discretization
essentially of
gradient flow dynamics has has linear
convergence so answer is yes to
both both questions uh
unfortunately you would have to you know
get familiar with the geometry in
discrete time case if you're familiar
with continuous time and
there is no free lunch there even for
experts i will control
control theorists you know this does not
come for free
yeah i was hoping for a freelancer
unfortunately
no even even we have preferences in
terms of you know
continuous time folks versus discrete
time and this is
very often for you know whatever you
become comfortable with first and
unfortunately in discrete time there are
some additional things that
that you need to pay attention but the
good news is that everything extends
so i can provide additional details if
you're interested and provide pointers
to the literature as well
yeah thanks it's amazing how nice this
is and considering how ugly q learning
is for lqr
and how elegant this is it's really
really surprising you know
i'll i'll just smile and plead the fifth
yeah okay
anything else out there because we could
we could um
we could chat for 20 minutes so we could
have a break
yeah so um okay
thank you guys okay so you you so anyway
so
we'll be back in 25 minutes for our next
talk and then right after that we'll be
up
okay ciao thanks sean